présidente messieurs mesdames les
sénateurs alors en effet quelques
chiffres et vous vous interrogez sur la
sous-déclaration en pharmacovigilance
qui en effet est une question récurrente
et on le sait il y a une sous
déclaration en pharmacovigilance mais en
moins sur cette campagne d'une ampleur
inédite nous sommes à la mi novembre à
plus de 110000 déclaration d'effets
indésirables pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur les années sans pandémie si
je puis dire on est plutôt autour de 45
mille événements indésirables qui sont
enregistrées dans la base nationale de
vigilance donc tout médicament
confondues exactement alors que la sur
les seuls effets indésirables des
vaccins on est à plus de 110000 j'ai
envie de dire même s'il gagne sous
déclaration on est quand même très
largement informés et la surveillance
porte véritablement sur l'ensemble des
effets juste quelques caractéristiques
également sur ses effets c'est vrai que
en règle générale pareil la déclaration
est
majoritairement fait tant parler les
professionnels de santé du fait de la
proximité notamment les centres
régionaux de pharmacovigilance des
professionnels de santé au sein des
centres hospitaliers universitaires
là on le voit au lieu d'être a autour de
90% de déclaration par les
professionnels de santé il ya un
rééquilibrage on a beaucoup plus de
déclaration par les patients on est en
train de regarder les chiffres on pourra
vous les donnez plus tard mais c'est
sans doute de l'ordre de 40 60 % 40 % de
patients contre 10% d'habitude et de
fait sur la répartition également entre
les cas graves et les cas graves là
aussi on est habituellement sur une
répartition qui est
autour de
40% de
2,2
pardon il faut que j'aurais pas de même
à la la on a beaucoup plus de gras
majoritairement aux graves en temps
normal et là on a plus nous déclarations
de d'événements non gras donc on le voit
on a une surveillance qui fonctionne à
la fois pour les effets un désir le
grave et les noms grave juste pour
revenir sur ce critère de gravité parce
que ça peut engendrer des problèmes
d'incompréhension la gravité en
pharmacovigilance elle est analysée au
regard de certains critères par exemple
si on est hospitalisé s'il ya une mise
en jeu du pronostic vital ou ou un décès
il ya aussi un critère qui est un
critère qui est du fait du professionnel
de santé qui va lui jugé que c'est
médicalement que l'effet médicalement
grave et donc de ce fait c'est un
critère qui est important bien
évidemment mais qui re qui rencontre un
peu plus de subjectivité que les
critères hospitalisation par exemple ou
décès et donc vous poser une question
par rapport aux déclarations des faits
graves et qu'elle était assez ses effets
graves qui étaient majoritairement
déclaré donc encore une fois gravité
elle correspond à 7 à la définition que
je vous ai rappelé mais il faut aussi
comprendre et madame matinée elle a dit
que les les effets déclaré les
déclarations sont ensuite analysés donc
par les centres régionaux de
pharmacovigilance qui va qui vont
déterminer si effectivement les faits et
bien lié au vaccin parfois ça peut être
lié à la vaccination par exemple on
arrive on est impressionné alors donc
c'est pas forcément liés au vaccin en
lui-même et c'est tout le travail
évidemment des centres que de regarder
ce lien est d'établir cette imputabilité
[Musique]